and we're about making this place in the
time that they come to take it the stand
off point we want to make this as ugly
and as difficult for the other side as
possible should the government be able
to tear down homes and businesses and
put a basketball Stadium in their place
that's what New York is doing right now
in Brooklyn it's really about community
you know it's about community and it's
about art and it's about embracing the
concept of an old saloon you know like
in the Old West when they were settling
a town the first building that they
would build to be the saloon it's a it's
a meeting place call it can be a
cultural center I love it because
everyone's friendly there's music
Esquire magazine one of the best bars in
America
timeout said Freddie's is perhaps the
ultimate saloon experience I like coming
here because of the environment and
because of the people a Village Voice
best bar in Brooklyn Village Voice best
videos in a bar there's awesome beers
the bartender's are so sweet our friends
we met here and they remained our
friends for you know God we've been here
12 years now you can feel it when you
when you first walk in the door there's
just like a power there's there's an
energy there's a warmth there's sort of
an excitement we're very proud of all
the elements you know the video the
music you know even the regulars now you
covet and develop regulars and we all
know each other's names here it's not
Cheers it's something much darker and
richer there's just so much going on
here and such a good good vibe by the
Atlantic the Atlantic Yards project is
basically a plan to build a basketball
Stadium for the New Jersey Nets in the
middle of a neighborhood that abuts
downtown Brooklyn it's a money-making
venture for a real estate tycoon named
Bruce Ratner who wants to build this
basketball stadium he's a part owner of
the nets and he plans to bring the nets
from New Jersey to Brooklyn but first
Ratner wants the government to help him
tear down Freddy's bar and other homes
and businesses in order to make room for
the stadium and Ratner isn't acting
alone his business partners include the
multi-millionaire rapper jay-z a Russian
bill
and the controversial community
organizing group a court they all want
their friends in big government to seize
land on behalf of radner's Atlantic
Yards project and most of our borough
[Music]
the New York state and the federal
constitutions allow for eminent domain
takings from what's called a public use
so what we have here is a classic case
of eminent domain abuse this is not a
public project this is not a road it's
in a highway it's not a bridge there's a
basketball Stadium for a private team
it's a private enterprise they're gonna
sell tickets the public can't just walk
in the door you gotta buy tickets I am
in favor of development I live in New
York City we wouldn't have a New York
City if it wasn't for development we
have a situation here where the referees
are bought off for us it's not a game
for us it's being under the thumb of
these people and the government which
they use as their as their instrument
the fight and Freddy's is a group of
patrons from Freddy's that do not want
to see the bar closed and we want to
save the neighborhood what's going on
here is wrong on top of wrong multiplied
by extra wrong and we're not afraid to
break the law I will handcuff myself to
this bar like I said in the show of my
solidarity and then and and other
members of the neighborhood and the
community and
sure willing to go to jail of course
what can I do to me our best option is
civil disobedience public action raising
public awareness this is more than just
the symbolic handcuffing we're about
bringing this law down we have a state
senator he's gonna lie down in front of
the bulldozer shall she'll be outside
she doesn't drink though we'll be inside
we've tried to make the cuffs long
enough so we can get to our beers
they're taking away my livelihood the
rest doesn't matter you know and my and
a great spot a great spot in the
neighborhood a thriving spot in the
neighborhood so yeah of course I'll be
here I will be here
I got a service lady some argue that
fighting for Freddie's bar is a lost
cause don't tell that to Donald Matthew
and Steve the Atlantic Yards project
isn't a legitimate public use it's a
land grab and if New York can tear down
Freddy's they can tear down any business
or home in the state that's eminent
domain abuse and it's got to stop for
reason TV I'm Nicholas
[Music]
you
[Music]